- I grew up in the family of skywriting.
I was just a little
kid, that's all I knew.
Just like being an artist of the sky.
I'm Greg Stinis, and I own
a company called SkyTypers
with my son, Stephen Stinis.
(calm music)
My dad was one of the original skywriters.
He started in 1931.
And one airplane travels a big circle
if he's gonna make an “o”
and that takes a lot of time to do that.
And he decided, "Hey,
there's gotta be a faster way
"to do this.
"I'll just do it with
a bunch of airplanes."
And so he came up with
the method of skytyping:
five airplanes flying in formation.
For instance, if we're gonna make an “i,”
everybody lets out just one puff.
There's your “i.”
If you wanna turn that
into an “l,” it's one puff,
plus the bottom guy lets
out three more puffs.
There's your “l.”
This is a very specialized form of flying.
Most of my pilots have got
like 10,000 flying hours,
so they're very experienced.
We fly AA-5B Tiger planes.
When we fly, it's roughly 45
minutes to get up to altitude,
which is 10,000 feet.
A typical skytyping message is
20 characters, sometimes 25,
and that's roughly five miles in length.
Each letter is the size of
the Empire State Building,
1,200 feet tall.
They're the biggest ads in the world
and you can't miss them.
The whole sky becomes your billboard.
(airplane starting)
I do this 'cause not only is it fun,
'cause I love flying,
but I like the
accomplishment of what we do,
'cause the people we fly for,
they're all thrilled.
We've gotten something like
120 years of skywriting
in the family.
My dad trained me, and I've trained my son,
and I'm very proud about the whole thing.